le nucléaire d'après vous jean marc
jancovici alors le nucléaire fait peur
dans les pays occidentaux
pour deux raisons à mon avis le premier
la première c'est qu'il fait appel à des
mécaniques à des mécanismes par donc on
est incapable d'apprécier avec nos sens
c'est une réaction nucléaire vous voyez
pas ce que c'est visuellement il ya un
aspect technique mais ce qui fait peur
sur le stream reliant c'est la peur de
l'accident c'est tchernobyl
oui je vais me après quand vous voyez
quelque chose qui brûle vos sens vous
dise ce que c'est donc vous en avez pas
trop peur et la combustion a fait des
dizaines de millions de morts dans le
monde
des dizaines de millions de morts sont
morts de jean pardon sont morts à cause
des explosions très loin il ya pas très
longtemps par exemple dans un port
chinois à cause d' usine qui ont pris
feu d'un incendie de gens qui sont morts
dans leur immeuble de etc pour autant on
dit pas faut interdire le feu et ça
c'est dû au fait que comme vos sens vous
permettre d'apprécier ce que c'est et
bien quelque part ça vous aide à
accepter le risque du risque nucléaire
vous voyez pas ce que c'est un
radioactivité c'est invisible avait
aucune idée en ce moment là on est tous
les deux radioactifs les tous les deux
radioactifs
parce que c'est pas pour autant lui fait
peur parce que votre corps contient du
carbone 14
petite partie du carbone présent sur
terre ce carbone 14 est radioactif
une bonne partie du potassium qu'on
consomme et qui est tout à fait
indispensable à notre métabolisme et du
potassium 40 qui radioactifs aussi et
donc si on perd mais cette comparaison
grivoises pendant l'acte sexuel
les amants échanges plus de becquerel de
spermatozoïdes d'accord donc la
radioactivité par tous par contre encore
une fois elle ne parle pas à nos sens
c'est invisible et en plus ça se mesure
avec des unités qui sont totalement
incompréhensibles
ce que je vais vous parler de becquerel
degré de 6 verte etc personne ne
comprend rien et alors à ce moment il ya
un premier effet qui s'applique qui est
l'effet côté obscur de la grotte savez
quand vous rentrez dans une grotte le
côté obscur c'est celui dont vous avez
la trouille parce que vous dites là il
doit y avoir une bestiole celle qui va
me sauter dessus et c'est donc quand
vous comprenez pas que vous
et pas que c'est inaccessible à vos sens
et c'est vous avez spontanément la
trouille et c'est normal c'est le
résultat de notre histoire
et si on vous dit on a détecté quelque
chose avec un appareil
une personne sur deux va se dire ah si
on a détecté sait que c'est dangereux
parce qu'ils aient pas vrai si j'appuie
avec mon doigt sur ma main je détecte la
pression c'est pas dangereux du tout bon
donc je peux très bien détecter sans que
ce soit dangereux mais il ya cet effet
là donc en gros il ya la peur de
l'inconnu
et puis les nucléaire sa série peur le
mot fait peur c'est il ya un autre une
autre raison pour laquelle ça fait peur
effectivement c'est quand on emploie le
même mot pour les armes et les les
centrales et puis il ya un dernier un
dernier point qui fait peur c'est ce que
j'appelle l'effet autobus alors l'effet
autobus since à tous les parents ont la
trouille de mettre leurs gosses dans un
autobus pour partir en colonie de
vacances
pourtant les statistiques vous montre
qu'ils courent beaucoup moins de risques
en étant dans l'autobus que quand leurs
parents les mêmes parents les emmène à
l'école tous les matins
pourquoi parce que quand un autobus à un
accident d'un seul coup d'un seul
sa face à des conséquences plus
spectaculaire est donc quand il ya un
accident d'autobus si on a eu 1 il ya
deux ans dans un tunnel suisse
l'actualité on a parlé pendant une
semaine ou quinze jours alors que sur
les quinze jours en question il est mort
pour un pato d'horreur raison des
milliers de personnes dans des tas
d'autres et non tombé dans les escaliers
sur les routes on n'en a pas parlé
donc c'est l'effet autobus donc
l'accident nucléaire qui est arrivé deux
fois à ce jour c'est quelque chose qui a
un côté spectaculaire qui masque la
réalité des statistiques ce que la
réalité des statistiques c'est que le
nucléaire est de très loin la manière la
plus sûre de produire de l'électricité
en grosse quantité
sauf si un accident oui mais cette même
cet accident ne change pas les
statistiques
tiens si vous incluez l'accident dans
les statistiques l'effet négatif d'un
accident n'est pas suffisant pour
compenser l'effet positif de tous les
moments où ça se passe bien oui mais les
conséquences de cet accident c'est
suffisamment alors ça c'est la croyance
couramment répandue en france et en fait
ça relève du même effet que le
climato-scepticisme c'est à dire c'est
des informations fausses qui tourne en
boucle sans qu'à aucun moment
il y ait une diffusion large de ce qu'il
en est vraiment il ya quelque chose qui
amuse toujours qui m'amuse toujours
quand j'en parle dans ce pays il existe
une commission onusienne qui s'occupe
d'étudier les dangers de la
radioactivité qui s'appelle lune ce
qu'est art absolument personne n'en
entends parler dans ces pays jolie nous
voilà et vous pas plus que les nombres
lune ce qu'ils arrêtent une commission
scientifique instaurée par les nations
unies par les nations unies qui a été
créé 30 ans avant le giec 30 ans avant
et qui a exactement la même fonction que
nous c'est à dire exactement la même
fonction que le giec c'est à dire
compiler ce qui se publie dans la
littérature scientifique dans le domaine
où on l'a chargé de le faire donc le
giec c'est le climat lutte car c'est la
radioactivité l'une sera sorti en avril
un rapport sur fukushima oui louis xiv
on peut y lire
le surplus de radioactivité relâchée
dans l'environnement n'aura pas de
conséquences pour les populations
il n'aura pas de conséquences pour
l'environnement mais c'est écrit presse
française n'a absolument pas parlé
donc vous voulez dire que le nucléaire
c'est pas dangereux je veux dire que ce
que dit la presse française quand elle
dit que le nucléaire c'est dangereux et
le résultat du fait que les journalistes
concernés ont été capturés par les
militants anti nucléaires et ont perdu
toute capacité à faire le tri dans les
informations qui sont disponibles et moi
là je lui quand même des reportages
reportage soirée journée oui mais qui
montrait je ne sais pas mais d'aider des
enfants malades autour décider des sites
de tours bilal qu'il ya des gens qui
soient malades autour de tchernobyl
si tchernobyl avait supprimé les rhumes
les entorses les nourritures les minimes
et les lecteurs les chercheurs 2000 n'a
pas supprimé les conseils 25% de la
population française va mourir d'un
cancer c'était déjà le cas avant
tchernobyl
donc il ya des tas de bonnes raisons de
se préoccuper des cancers ya
probablement des choses liées aux
activités humaines qui n'y sont pas pour
rien mais mais affirmer tchernobyl a
augmenté le nombre de cancers ne
correspond pas à ce qui se trouve dans
les reports de musique et arts
alors qu'ils contribuent au rapport de
l'unité arabe c'est le même système de
fonctionnement que le giec
vous avez dans le monde des armes et de
biologistes deux médecins deux
physiciens etc de gens qui s'intéressent
à ce genre de choses des gens qui font
des études de cohorte chez les médecins
des biologistes qui font des études en
laboratoire il était plein ces gens-là
publie et la synthèse de leurs
publications et ce qu'on trouve dans le
rapport de l'usc est rare et il ya de
très bonnes raisons que l'une des rares
conclut ça je vais vous donner un
exemple avec l'unité qui est utilisé
pour mesurer la dangerosité de la
radioactivité qui elle aussi verte
et c'est sous multiples en particulier
mélicie verte les gens dans
l'environnement de fukushima ont reçu en
moyenne quelques milli sieverts en plus
à cause de l'accident
elle va quelques milli sievert en plus
c'est ce que prend une hôtesse de l'air
de chez easyjet tous les ans je ne crois
pas qu'on ait interdit les vols chez
easyjet et je ne crois pas qu'on est
interdit d'être hôtesse de l'air chez
easyjet
parce que le fait de voyager en ça
rapproche des oriels du rayonnement
cosmique et ça fait qu'on prend un peu
plus de radioactivité
vous avez des régions dans le monde
parfaitement habitées dont une province
indienne s'appelle le kerala où
l'environnement à cause des roches vous
envoie spontanément une radioactivité
chaque année qui vous explose à quelque
chose qui est de l'ordre de 50
millisieverts par an il n'y a
strictement aucun effet dans la
population
mieux encore mais je pense pas qu'il ya
un lien de cause à effet là là moi
comment dire l'espérance de vie dans
cette province est supérieure à ce
qu'elle est pour l'inde dans son
ensemble vous avez également des plages
au brésil qui sont connus pour avoir une
radioactivité naturelle raisonnablement
élevé dont certaines pas loin de rio on
les a pas interdites à la fréquentation
de la population donc en fait il s'est
passé quelque chose avec le nucléaire
qui est très fréquent en matière de
risques technologiques d'une manière
beaucoup plus large et de risques
environnementaux beaucoup plus large
c'est que la décision politique
on en parlera peut-être un autre moment
souvent a du mal à être raccord avec la
connaissance scientifique
on le voit dans le cas du changement
climatique ou la décision publique n'est
pas assez courageuse sur le fait de
limiter les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre et en sens inverse
on le voit sur le nucléaire ou la
décision publique conduit à prendre un
excès de précaution par rapport à ce que
la science nous dit sur la dangerosité
réelle
la de la radioactivité ça peut jouer
dans un sens comme dans l'autre vous
voulez dire que les politiques sont pas
informés non les sites politiques sont
mal informés alors on n'aurait pas le
temps de toutes façons de lire eux-mêmes
toute la production scientifique ça fait
beaucoup trop par contre dans les
démocraties occidentales
ils ont globalement du mal à avoir un
rapport de confiance avec les experts
qui pourrait leur dire c'est ça la
conclusion à laquelle il faut faire
confiance et donc il est légitime de
base est la décision publique sur ça et
pas sur autre chose
ce rapport là il a tendance à se
distendre avec le temps dans un monde
qui devient de plus en plus complexes
avec des intérêts économiques qui sont
de plus en plus présent et donc un jeu
qui devient beaucoup plus compliqué et
en plus des élus qui ont pas le temps
pour eux parce que s'imprégner de ce
genre de choses c'est beaucoup plus
rentable si vous savez que vous allez
pouvoir vous en servir pendant longtemps
si vous avez besoin de quatre ans pour
comprendre ce que cette le changement
climatique et ensuite vous allez vous
voir vous en servir pendant six mois
seulement vous n'avez pas envie de faire
quoi
donc il ya il ya tout un tas de facteurs
qui explique ça mais ça concerne le
nucléaire comme ça concerne plein
d'autres choses
alors pour en fit don quand vous le
nucléaire pour en finir 10 et enfin il
n'y a pas de raison d'avoir peur du
nucléaire les militants anti nucléaires
par exemple sont des gens mal informés
alors je ne sais pas s'ils sont mal
informés en tout cas je pense qu'ils
militent pour une mauvaise idée un peu
différent dans le contexte dans lequel
on est moi je ne crois pas au monde
merveilleux
sinon je rajeunirait de 20 ans je
prendrais 10 cm avons vu passer à
l'étape qui manifestement ne se passe
pas donc le monde merveilleux n'existe
pas dans le monde dans lequel on vit
la bonne question à se poser c'est pas
est ce que demain matin je peux avoir le
monde merveilleux
c'est parmi toutes les options qui sont
à ma main aujourd'hui quelle est la
moins mauvaise ou la meilleure que je
puisse prendre et dans ce monde-là
décidé aujourd'hui qu'on va diminuer le
nucléaire plutôt que de l'augmenter
c'est globalement augmenté les risques
globaux concours corse est globalement
augmenté les risques concours c'est ça
la conclusion donc je suis comme je suis
pas pour qu'on augmente les risques
concours de manière globale bah je suis
pour qu'on augmente la part du nucléaire
maintenant ça suffit absolument pas en
tant que tel à traiter tous les
problèmes qui sont devant nous c'est pas
parce qu'on fait plus de nucléaire que
les primes du changement climatique sont
résolus en totalité
parce que le nucléaire concerne la
production électrique ça concerne pas
les transports ça concerne pas le fioul
dans l'industrie ça concerne pas le gaz
dans l'industrie sans faille à l'état de
trucs que ça concerne pas et ça concerne
pas les émissions agricoles
il ya un autre problème avec le
nucléaire ce sont les déchets alors les
déchets c'est un problème qu'il a aussi
a beaucoup plus d'importance dans le
débat public qu'il n'en a dans la
réalité je vais donner juste deux
exemples histoire de pas être trop long
le premier exemple c'est qu'il ya un
réacteur naturel qui a fonctionné à au
clos au gabon il ya deux milliards
d'années
donc les conditions étaient réunies pour
que à cet endroit là il ya deux
milliards d'années
il ya une réaction de fission qui se
déclenchent naturellement dans une mine
d'uranium qui avait donc ça fait 200
cherhal nucléaire naturel centrales
nucléaires naturel donc ça fait des
déchets première conclusion qu'on peut
tirer de cette expérience c'est que
l'existence de ces déchets n'a
manifestement pas supprimer toute vie
sur terre puisque nous sommes là tous
les deux eu apparemment bien portant en
train de deviser gaiement sur l'avenir
du monde
oui c'est peut-être une question de
quantité oui ça on est bien d'accord
mais il n'empêche
la deuxième chose encore plus
intéressante qu'on peut tirer de cette
expérience c'est que les descendants de
ces déchets du caire je les déchets
nucléaires sont radioactifs donc très
vite ils vont se transformer en autre
chose et bien le des est ce autre chose
s'appelle des descendants et bien les
descendants de ces déchets nucléaires
sont très exactement là où les déchets
ont été formés
donc les déchets c'est pas un truc qui
va avoir des petites pattes et qui va
commencer à se balader partout les
déchets ces espèces de cailloux vous les
mettez dans un endroit il bouge pas et
le confinement géologique est quelque
chose qui dure beaucoup plus longtemps
que les cent mille ans qui nous font si
peur
un fossile par exemple une ammonite ou
un truc comme ça quand vous le trouvez
la couche dans lequel vous le trouvez
arrive à me procurer un confinement aux
fossiles qui a duré des dizaines de
millions d'années un réservoir de
pétrole
c'est quelque chose qui a été confinée
pendant des dizaines de millions
d'années
ça tient très bien d'accord
jean bien on s'en fout en termes
géologiques sais rien donc l'idée que si
on met ses déchets dans une couche
géologique
ils vont nous sauter à la figure demain
matin et contaminer toute vie sur terre
c'est de l'ordre de face et c'est
comment dire un peu violent si je
qualifie sa de fantasmes mais enfin
c'est on n'en est pas très loin
c'est de l'ordre de la peur un peu
irraisonnée en fait c'est pas en suède
il ya eu un grand débat sur les déchets
nucléaires il ya une dizaine d'années
qui a été menée d'une manière très
intelligente le gouvernement s'est donné
les moyens de payer une petite équipe
qui a fait toutes les arrière-cuisines
de suède par groupes de 20 personnes
pour passer deux heures à dire les
déchets c'est sans les options qu'on a
sous la main c'est ça
voilà comment se présente le débat en
résultant le débat se passe très bien
d'accord rien à ajouter lcf la chine en
français
où
lcf vive la chine en français
jean marc jancovici aujourd'hui les
questions liées à l'environnement et au
changement climatique ne sont plus
seulement le terrain des activistes et
des amoureux de la nature mais aussi
celui des hommes d'affaires et des
grosses entreprises
pour résumer aujourd'hui économie et
écologie ne sont plus des termes
antinomiques bien au contraire et c'est
d'ailleurs ce à quoi vous oeuvrez dans
votre projet le shift project et dans
votre cabinet de conseil carbone 4 aider
les entreprises à avoir un comportement
plus favorables à la protection de
l'environnement
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
justement ce changement autrefois les
entreprises c'était celles qui
polluaient les méchantes pollueuses et
puis il y avait de l'autre côté les
gentils environnementalistes qui
cherchait à défendre la planète
pourquoi tout ça a changé comment tout
ça a changé ce qui n'a pas changé c'est
que les entreprises continuent à être
des méchantes pollueuses là les
pollutions de toutes natures n'ont
jamais été aussi élevées qu'aujourd'hui
si on regarde les émissions de co2 la
consommation en ressources non
renouvelables la déforestation etc
ou alors c'est le discours qui a chaud
alors exactement ce qui a changé c'est
la prise de conscience c'est à dire que
il ya trente ans le monde économique
était globalement dans un discours de
type circulez ya rien à voir
l'environnement est bien assez vaste
pour que je continue à faire comme avant
et on s'occupera du problème plus tard
et c'est écolo il en chine aujourd'hui
une bonne partie et ça c'est parce que
quelques dizaines d'années
d'explications scientifiques sont passés
derrière une bonne partie des dirigeants
d'entreprise ne sont pas hostiles à
accepter l'idée que l'on vit sur une
planète finie donc une planète finie dit
que quand les hommes commencent à
devenir trop envahissante mais à avoir
des problèmes et c'est exactement ce
qu'on est en train de vivre de manière
accélérée
aujourd'hui
la première tentative de rapprocher les
raisonnements économiques des limites
physiques de la planète
à ma connaissance enfin la première
pratique la première tentative qui a eu
un grand retentissement c'est ce qu'on a
appelé le club de rome ou plus
exactement
l'ouvragé emblématique qui avait été
publié sous l'égide de clubs du club de
rome qui s'appelait les limites à la
croissance cette année 1972 72 donc 72
et c'était donc le titre anglais était
de limitrophes et ça disait bien ce que
ça disait c'est à dire que c'était un
essai d'appréciation de à quelle
distance sommes-nous de la limite à la
croissance mais quand donc ça fait donc
une quarantaine d'années qu'on en parle
et quelques mois quelques années à tout
cas c'est qu'on essaye d'agir à comment
ça se fait que cela est vrai alors ça a
pris beaucoup de bas toujours pareil
parce qu'on fait confiance à notre sens
à nos sens et on est des animaux donc on
est bien au sens alors il se trouve que
de limitrophes est arrivé deux ans avant
le premier choc pétrolier donc à ce
moment les gens se sont dit c'est vrai
c'est un peu comme vous avez un discours
sur le changement climatique en juin
2003 et en août 2003 les gens vous
disent ah bah oui c'est vrai d'accord ça
des fellahs qui a qui jouent après
arrive le contrechoc le contrechoc bas
prix du pétrole etc et le discours et va
donc le cours du pétrole est pas un
mauvais indicateur de
du discours environnementaliste et puis
ce qui s'est passé il ya eu un
changement de génération vous savez
qu'en général ils font un changement de
génération pour que les mentalités
changent dans le monde agricole
papa faisait du conventionnel fiston
fera du bio c'est ça le pas de temps et
bien dans le monde économique c'est
aussi un peu ça le peu de temps donc là
pour vous ça se renouvelle et puis les
nouveaux il résonne un peu différemment
ce qui aujourd'hui aussi a changé dans
le monde économique c'est qu'une
fraction croissante des entreprises
comprennent que ll on démarre on a tiré
du feu oui elles ont un intérêt à l'aide
alors pas tout à tout je suis un
distributeur
le carrefour ou auchan dans un monde
dans lequel je me restreins sur la prise
sur le prélèvement de ressources et sur
l'énergie fabriquer des objets va coûter
plus cher donc j'en vendrais - donc je
fais de mauvaise affaire donc je suis
distributeurs j'ai aucune envie que la
limite environnementale existe le
mettant donné que tous les autres
distributeurs sont concernés par les
mêmes contraintes
alors je peux éventuellement me dire moi
je suis pour la contrainte si je pense
que je suis celui qui va y résister le
mieux est à ce moment ça fait le ménage
et ça me supprime un concurrent
ce raisonnement on le voit de temps en
temps je connais des gens qui sont dans
des industries assez polluantes et qui
milite pour que la pression globale
augmente parce qu'ils se disent c'est
pas moi le maillon faible dans cette
histoire donc ça va me virer un
concurrent et notamment dans les
secteurs qui sont déjà un peu au niveau
local oligopolistique garer
typiquement certains matériaux de base
et bien vous avez des acteurs qui se dit
je suis pour augmenter la contrainte
parce que pour le moment c'est un jeu à
quatre ça va en virée un jeu à trois
quand même plus sympa même si le terrain
de jeu est un peu plus petit donc ça
peut exister mais ça devient un intérêt
direct égoïste à l'action et pour avoir
un intérêt direct et égoïste à l'action
faut comprendre que c'est le cas et pour
y arriver faut bien une génération donc
en fait ce qui s'est passé en une
génération c'est qu'un certain nombre de
gens comprennent que très égoïstement si
on durcit la contrainte
eh bien ça va faire ménage chez les
autres avant de faire mes achats chez
eux et donc ils ont plutôt des avantages
que des inconvénients à en retirer
et puis aujourd'hui ses 20 margut mans
devons aussi alors ça peut l'être qu'on
appelle le greenwashing d'ailleurs oui
alors le lacet greenwashing quand on
change rien sur la manière de faire avec
le consommateur est persuadé que vous
faites mieux bon et que ça coûte pas
plus cher que du bonheur
vous allez vendre et tout le monde sera
content vous avez peu de consommateurs
ça c'est la réalité qui sont prêts à
payer significativement plus cher
quelque chose qui a des vertus
environnementales et strictement
environnementales meyer avait dit c'est
pas vrai le bio ça fait 10 % et c'est
parce que le consommateur est persuadé
que c'est meilleur pour sa santé si vous
pouviez lui démontrer ce que je ne sais
pas si c'est vrai mais si vous pouviez
lui démontrer qu'il n'y a pas d'effet
sur la santé je pense que le bio ne
ferait pas les taux de pénétration qui
fait aujourd'hui alors je vais dire
l'argument sanitaire et l'argument
environnemental souvent ils sont proches
oui oui de fait d'accord de temps en
temps ils sont liés mais il n'empêche
que l'argument environnemental stricto
sensu
il déplace 2 ou 3 % des consommateurs si
vous voulez qu'ils déplacent plus il
faut le traduire dans ce que fait le
consommateur toujours et tout le temps
c'est à voter que son portefeuille
donc il faut que le produit qui est pas
sympathique pour l'environnement quelque
part finissent par coûter plus cher que
le produit qui est sympathique pour
l'environnement vous n'avez que deux
manières de faire ça pour subventionner
le produit qui est sympathique pour
l'environnement à un moment vous
assécher les finances publiques ça
marche pas parce que quand vous
subventionnez un truc émergents ça va
bien c'est pas beaucoup d'argent si vous
subventionnez une consommation de masse
là ça commence à vous poser de sérieux
problèmes
le raisonnement inverse consiste à taxer
ce qui pose problème c'est par exemple
l'idée de la taxe carbone la taxe
carbone c'est une idée très simple c'est
de taxer de manière progressive l'usagé
des combustibles fossiles
c'est juste ça puisque italienne celle
des états parce qu'ils contiennent du
carbone à l'échelle des états et donc ça
rend progressivement de plus en plus
cher d'utiliser toujours la même
quantité de combustible fossile donc ça
va vous orienter naturellement vers des
voitures qui consomment de moins en
moins des logements de mieux en mieux
isoler des chaudières de plus en plus
efficace où vous passez à la pompe à
chaleur etc etc
ça va ça va naturellement vous orienter
vers ça dans un système de marché
c'est ça c'est ça les pricipaux mieux en
plus c'est cher exactement plus ces
polluants plus c'est cher c'est une
application par milo du principe
pollueur payeur
vous avez donc alors ça en général ça
n'a pas la faveur du monde politique
parce que le monde politique aime bien
promettre la lune
et quand vous promettez aux gens qu'ils
vont payer plus de taxes c'est pas la
lune
c est plutôt l inverse alors
personnellement je pense que c'est quand
même une bonne idée parce que cette taxe
moi je la vois comme une prime
d'assurance sur l'assurance en général
les gens considèrent que c'est légitime
je paye un peu aujourd'hui pour me
couvrir contre un risque demain qui
pourrait me faire beaucoup plus mal
taxe carbone c'est ça ou payer un peu
aujourd'hui pour éviter demain un
changement climatique dont vous n'aurez
pas les moyens d'assumer les
conséquences
exactement le principe de l'assurance
donc si vous présentez comme ça ce n'est
pas spécialement et les cotisations
d'assurance obligatoire je rappelle vous
êtes locataire vous êtes obligé de vous
assurez vous êtes homo bi liste vous
êtes obligé de vous assurer donc vous
êtes propriétaire j'étais obligé de vous
assurez vous êtes chef d'entreprise une
sorte d'assurance et contre l'objet de
chez gagneront qui met donc c'est une
assurance contre le changement
climatique la taxe carbone c'est ça le
principe est ce un énorme avantage par
rapport à ja temps juste que le prix du
pétrole au prix du gaz augmente c'est
quand le prix du pétrole ou prix du gaz
augmente et que vous êtes importateurs
de pétrole et gaz l'argent il part chez
les autres et donc vous avez plus cet
argent pour en faire des choses chez
vous quand c'est une taxe qui augmente
c'est une circulation intérieure dire
que l'argent en vous le prendre votre
poche gauche et après l'état le
dépensent dans votre poche droite et il
fait des médecins des hôpitaux des
routes non pas des routes parce qu'il ya
des voitures dessus les chemins de fer
etc de l'éducation et mai
éventuellement horreur des subventions
un certain nombre de trucs qui peuvent
être utiles donc le la taxe même si on
pense que nos politiques sont incapables
ce qui est parfois vrai que nos
fonctionnaires sont feignants ce qui est
parfois vrai c'est quand même de
l'argent qui reste chez nous et moi je
préfère dans une certaine mesure payer
les fonctionnaires feignant de chez moi
plutôt que les fonctionnaires fainéants
des autres raconte barre des chemins
séparés quand même un peu mieux donc le
genre revient aux entreprises
oui alors revenons à la question de
comment les entre les entreprises vont
elles pouvoir continuer à croître tout
en août elles vont pas céder à la
question c'est quand même c'est le
discours qu'on entend aujourd'hui oui
économie écologie tout tout tout tout
marche très bien ensemble etc
on va continuer à se faire dans l'argent
voilà tout est dans l'art 1 les
entreprises et entre des entreprises oui
c'est tout là et c'est tout le problème
on ne fait pas de changement on ne
change on ne règle pas un problème sans
changer les règles du jeu
on ne change pas les règles du jeu sans
faire des gagnants et des perdants et là
on a gagné là il faut se renvoyer à
machiavel les gagnants on ne sait pas
qui c'est parce que les règles du jeu
viennent de changer donc c'est un peu
difficile de savoir qui va gagner puis
son futur pour partie les enfants qui
naissent aujourd'hui font partie des
gagnants de la faire ils n'ont pas voix
au chapitre
une intersyndicale des bébés les
nourrissons qui est là pour dire payer
donc la taxe carbone il n'existe de bain
alors que les perdants ils savent tout
de suite qui y sont parce que c'est ce
qu'ils sont devenus puissants avec les
règles du jeu pour existantes dont ils
savent tout de suite qu'ils sont et à ce
moment c'est quelque chose qui est très
bien décrit dans le prince
les perdants vous les voyez tous défilé
dans votre bureau et donc vous avez
l'impression que vous avez l'impression
qu'ils vous changer avec du jeu vous ne
ferait que des perdants
c'est quelque chose qui dissuade
fortement l'action d'eaux mais il ya
aussi des risques on voit surtout je
trouve c'est que des grosses entreprises
qui ont les moyens justement de
s'adapter aux nouvelles règles du jeu
prennent les devants aujourd'hui et
c'est certainement celle qui sont
d'ailleurs les plus grosses vagues les
plus gros pollueurs aujourd'hui qu'ils
vont réussir à cette transition soit
parce qu'elles ont plus de moyens que
non plus petit
ça dépend alors il ya 2 il ya deux
grandes familles de
de d'action quand on veut résoudre le
problème du changement climatique une
première famille d'action qui est
consommé moins consommer moins c'est ce
qu'on a coutume de qualifier de sobriété
si c'est vous qui choisissez et de
pauvreté si vous l'avez si vous avez
rien demandé à personne
donc si on vous force à consommer moins
alors que vous avez rien demandé à
personne c'est de la pauvreté ou la
précarité
si vous l'avez délibérément choisi ses
de la sobriété pour ça qu'on dit souvent
volontaire enfin la sobriété
involontaire c'est de la pauvreté et la
restriction donc la différence entre la
restriction et la sobriété ne tient que
dans le mental des gens à qui ça
s'applique c'est juste ça qui fait la
différence
l'autre grande marge de manoeuvre c'est
ce qu'on appelle l'efficacité donc
l'efficacité c'est je me prive de rien
juste les objets que j'ai à ma
disposition on à utiliser moins
d'énergie pour les fabriquer et il
consomme moins quand le cancer
on ne fera pas l'économie de la sobriété
on ne peut pas y arriver sans sobriété
ça marchera pas donc ça veut dire qu'il
faut comprendre quelque part une forme
de décroissance socialement acceptable
mais saison ces grosses entreprises
elles ont pas envie de décroître
pas du tout on est bien d'accord et cdc
bien le sujet en tout cas ils n'ont pas
envie décroître elle donc un monde dans
lequel elle elle croise et tous les
autres décroissent ça leur va très bien
on va très bien ils sont pas payés pour
faire le bonheur du monde
ils sont payés pour faire le bonheur de
leurs actionnaires ou de leurs salariés
ou leurs clients etc mais pas le bonheur
donc ça ça leur va très bien par contre
si la totalité suit ce chemin là toute
entreprise sera content donc il ya quand
même des gens qui ont de meilleures
affaires à faire dans ce monde là c'est
par exemple les gens qui opèrent des
transports collectifs
à commencer par les bus pas parler train
parce que les bûches c'est quelque chose
qui se met en place
beaucoup plus rapidement que les trains
pour substituer des voitures les gens
qui pourraient faire de meilleures
affaires c'est les constructeurs de
petites voitures
si demain matin je décide que le parc
automobile en circulation en france
n'augmente pas en taille
j'entends pays en voiture mais je passe
toutes les voitures de 6 litre à 2
litres à celui qui sert à fabriquer des
voitures à 2 litres
pendant un temps il va faire de très
bonnes affaires il faut que je mette en
place le bon système que je taxe le plus
en plus les sens que je mette une
vignette c'est à dire que les gens
payent un impôt annuel qui est
proportionnelle à la consommation de la
voiture subventionner l'achat
la voiture du resto fabre a échoué en
place le bon système les gens qui
fabrique les voitures font très bonnes
affaires les autres non si je mets en
place partout des bus pour remplacer une
partie des voitures dans les
déplacements pour aller au travail
les gens qui vendent les bus sont très
bonnes affaires les gens qui vend des
voitures - dont je peut favoriser des
gagnants et pendant un temps vont faire
de très bonnes affaires
tu peux très bien y en avoir il faut
juste que ces gens là ils comprennent
que ça va être qu'ils vont faire de
bonnes affaires et donc du coup ils
deviennent très allants sur le fait
qu'on va vraiment s'occuper du problème
dans le domaine de l'énergie
si je décide de remplacer des centrales
à charbon par de l'électricité
décarbonée les gens qui vendent des
centrales nucléaires ou des éoliennes ou
des barrages ils vont faire de très
bonnes affaires
et puis les gens qui vendent des
centrales à charbon ou faire le très
mauvaise affaire
les gens qui exploitent des mines de
charbon faire de très mauvaise affaire
donc il ya il faut trouver pour avancer
en fait un nombre suffisant d'entreprise
à qui on est capable de dire vous vous
faites partie des gens qui vont faire de
très bonnes affaires et vous pouvez très
bien faire de très bonnes affaires dans
un ensemble global qui se contracte je
vais finir par un exemple historique pas
très gai pour les gens qui ont été
concernés mais quand même historique
dans l'effondrement post-soviétique de
la russie le pib russe s'est contracté
de 40%
ça n'a pas empêché des groupes
industriels de se constituer et
d'immenses fortunes d'apparaître donc le
fait que des gens puissent faire de très
bonnes affaires dans un monde qui
globalement se contracte sur le plan
économique c'est tout à fait possible
pour elle c'est déjà arrivé
oui simplement le problème c'est que
même s'il sert pas bon on peut s'adapter
indéfiniment mais il ya un moment où de
toutes les manières à chaque fois qu'on
continue de produire qu'on continue de
consommer on participe à ce fameux
réchauffement de la planète
or aujourd'hui il est urgent de le
stopper et même de le diminuer
donc il ya de toutes les manières une
limite à tout ça non oui bien sûr alors
il ya une première limite qui est con on
a besoin de manger tant qu'on est en vie
donc 7 milliards de bons hommes de toute
façon il y aura les émissions liées à
leur alimentation
on peut pas y couper alors on peut les
baisser ses émissions liées à
l'alimentation par exemple - ont mis en
mange de viande rouge
me faire aimer des éleveurs ils sont
déjà pas à la fête il ya une manière de
concilier les deux - on mange de viande
rouge est mieux le climat ce porte parce
que 80% de la production végétale dans
les pays comme la france sert à nourrir
des animaux donc les 106 ch
non il s'agit exactement donc tous les
champs de maïs servent à nourrir des
animaux une bonne partie des champs de
blé servent à nourrir les animaux tous
les champs de luzerne servent à nourrir
des animaux vont bref une bonne partie
des chances et on va nourrir les animaux
les animaux ils ont la mauvaise idée de
péter et dropt et ceux qui émettent du
méthane dans l'atmosphère qui est un gaz
à effet de serre très puissants
non seulement ils sont mal élevés mais
en plus ça participe au réchauffement
climatique est par ailleurs quand on
utilise des engrais azotés dans les
champs au moment où on est pensé en
grèce a aimé aussi un gaz qui
participent au réchauffement climatique
donc en gros la viande rouge c'est pas
une très bonne idée d'en manger beaucoup
si on veut lutter contre le changement
climatique mais une fois que j'ai 17
milliards de mon homme doivent manger
après il ya des tas de trucs qui sont
arbitrable c'est pas sûr qu'en france il
faille une voiture par ménage peut-être
qu'on peut s'organiser avec moins et est
resté à peu près heureux de vivre tant
même du reste les jeunes ils ont de plus
en plus tendance à s'organiser sans vous
avez également aujourd'hui une
augmentation de l'espace habitable par
personne peut-être que c'est pas la
peine de continuer on est déjà pas mal
avec l'espace habitable dont on dispose
aujourd'hui peau tellement la peine de
l'augmenter donc il ya un certain nombre
de choses qui va falloir qu'ils vont
impliquer les consommateurs et c'est
clair que résoudre le problème du
changement climatique sans impliquer le
consommateur d'accord ça ne marche pas
mais alors là on était du côté des
entreprises
question oui alors le problème c'est que
le consommateur c'est son client alors
une entreprise peut difficilement dire à
un client a acheté moins de mon produit
j'en connais pas beaucoup qui sont
prêtes à dire ça donc ce que les
entreprises sont prêtes à faire au mieux
c'est de mourir sans mettre la société à
feu et à sang
quand elles ont fait leur temps vous
leurs conseillers
moi je m'occupe plutôt de celle qui
alors non pardon je m'occupe de deux
catégories d'entreprises les premières à
qui je dis vous savez en tendance vous
êtes plutôt du côté de celles qui vont
mourir donc occuper vous d'essayer de
faire autre chose même si ça fait moins
de chiffre d'affaires ou même si etc qui
va vous permettre de gagner en pérennité
et puis celles qui sont déjà installés
sur des créneaux où elles peuvent amener
une valeur à la société pour résoudre ce
problème tout en faisant de meilleures
affaires
celle là évidemment c'est celle que j'ai
particulièrement envie de conseiller
dans la lcf
si la chine en français
oh
lcf vif la chine en français
alors jean marc jancovici quand on parle
des questions relatives au problème du
climat
on a l'impression un petit peu qu'il
faut choisir entre la peste et le
choléra cessé de se laver enfin nous
alors je ne sais pas arrêté de se
chauffer enfin on entend toutes sortes
de solutions
comment se fait-il que les choses et si
peu avancé en la matière qu'on ne sache
toujours pas ce qu'il faut faire
alors que ça fait des décennies qu'on
parle de ses problèmes
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'avance pas alors
on avance pas parce que résoudre le
problème du changement climatique sans
toucher à la consommation n'est pas
possible
et aujourd'hui la quasi totalité des
pays qui participent aux problèmes
climatiques donc les émetteurs de gaz à
effet de serre à l'exception notable de
la chine dont on reparlera peut-être
sont des démocraties et la démocratie
est un système non contraignant l'an
pato n'en est indécis et ça c'est le
grand maître tocqueville qui l'avait
déjà expliqué il ya maintenant pas loin
de deux siècles donc dans les
démocraties vous ne vous fait pas élire
en disant aux consommateurs je vais vous
contraindre sarkozy rappelez vous
c'était le président du pouvoir d'achat
hollande c'était le président de jeu
pourquoi avec plein de croissance
partout enfin bon donc vous fait pas
élire en promettant la restriction le de
la deuxième caractéristique de cette
affaire c'est que la démocratie crée le
sentiment d'injustice
elle a aussitôt qu'il l'avait très bien
expliqués en aristocratie les choses
sont figés tiens vous fils de baron vous
serez baron fils de rien du tout rien du
tout du coup il ya un fatalisme qui
s'installe dans la population qui ne
considère pas qu'il est injuste que son
sort ne s'améliore pas au cours de sa
vie parce que les choses sont ainsi
écrite que vous appartenez à une espèce
une caste jeu pourquoi est il est dit
dans les règles de vie en commun ne vous
en sortirez pas en démocratie il est dit
que les droits de tous sont égaux
donc si vous et moi on est nés la même
année on a suivi les mêmes études et que
aujourd'hui
gagner plus que moi c'est pas juste or
donc la démocratie elle pousse à
exacerber un sentiment d'injustice donc
un sentiment de revendication est donc
une ça exacerbe les tendances sur
l'accumulation dit autrement tant qu'il
existe quelqu'un quelque part sur cette
planète ou plus exactement dans mon pays
qui a plus que moi il n'y a pas de
raison que moi je me prive nom serait
très répandues comme sentiment et ça
c'est la contrepartie du système
politique dont nous savons tous que
c'est le pire à l'exception de tous les
autres
donc il a sevré travers et le dirigeant
en place comme il est là pour un temps
court il peut même pas se dire c'est pas
grave je vais commencer par faire des
choses où je vais pas me faire aimer
mais je suis là pour 40 ans
l'histoire jugera et au bout du bout on
constatera que j'ai eu raison de faire
ça il peut pas tenir ce genre de
raisonnement
parce qu'il est sur des mandats trop
court par ailleurs comme on l'a dit dans
un cadre précédent fin dans une émission
précédente il il le dirigeant politique
au moment où ils arrivent au pouvoir
le fait d'être élu ne le rend pas
instantanément compétent sur un problème
technique particulier
par manque de connaissance il a les
connaissances le lendemain de son
accession au pouvoir qu'il avait la
veille
pas plus pas moins donc comme il n'a pas
la science infuse
il n'a pas en main toutes les cartes
pour commencer à s'attaquer au problème
le lendemain matin du jour de son
élection est en général le temps qu'ils
finissent par comprendre de quel
problème on parle on n'est pas très loin
de l'élection suivante
malheureusement pas s'il faut donc vous
avez un vrai problème de 2,2
d'inadéquation entre le pacte ans avec
lequel on raisonne dans l'action
publique et le pas de temps qui
caractérise le problème parce que
changer l'urbanisme changer les
bâtiments changer les modes de transport
changer les habitudes alimentaires
changent et le prix dans les magasins
changer l'urbanisme industriel
c'est-à-dire là où on a mis les usines
et besoins de communication que sacrés
ensemble etc
ses 50 ans mais enfin on en est déjà à
50 on est à 50 ans entre jours de la
conférence de rome 1972 on est à 50 ans
justement sans avoir rien changé malin
parce qu on essaye de s'attaquer à un
problème je prends un parallèle qui vaut
ce qu'il vaut
il ya deux manière d'élever les enfants
une manière à et de leur conserver les
mêmes parents habitant sous le même toit
ensemble pour en 25 ans et une manières
b1 ces clasicos et de divorcer et tous
les trois ans voire encore pire qu'ils
aient plus de parents et qui change de
familles d'accueil tous les trois ans à
votre avis c'est quoi la méthode qui
donne les meilleurs résultats
bon donc non mais c'est très facile et
pour première réponse
en démocratie on a l'option b c'est à
dire que tous les trois ans ou tous les
cinq ans on change les gens à qui on
doit rendre des comptes ou qu'ils nous
donnent des directions à suivre qui eux
mêmes en cours de mandat sont capables
de changer du tout au tout selon pas
être pourquoi donc vous avez assez un
système qui est très très peu
contraignant pour les orientations
structurelles de long terme
en fait la démocratie est un système
remontant la démocratie produit des
choses au niveau du pouvoir central
quand une fraction suffisante de la base
a fini par dire qu'il fallait s'occuper
du problème
c'est dans ce sens là que ça marche et
on a l'illusion que c'est un système
descendants parce que on sort de
milliers d'années d'une histoire qui est
monarchique ou assimilés aux chefs de
tribus le chef de la ville j'avais donc
on a un moment on a un souverain de
droit divin ou un chef de droit divin
raisonnablement avec le pouvoir qui se
transmet d'une manière lente
le patron de la tribu après la mort du
chef ce n'est pas nécessairement le fils
du chef mais enfin celui qu'on va
choisir il va pas on va pas le dégager
au bout d'une semaine
donc il ya on sort de cette histoire
multimillénaire avec un pouvoir de droit
divin lent et on est rentré dans un
système qui est sans grand effet
coercitif et remontant non pas du tout
avec quelqu'un qui dit je veux c'est
comme ça que ça va se passer mais c'est
tout l'inversé
regarde les sondages tous les quatre
matins et il fait ce que lui dit la
majorité et c'est pour ça qu'on avance
et c'est pour ça qu'on n'avance pas
alors ça m'amène soit dit en passant à
une conclusion qui est peut-être pas
très gai qui est ça va mais aussi à une
conclusion qui est que je pense que
l'europe se trompe de partenaire quand
elle pense que c'est avec les états unis
qu'il est le plus urgent de discuter des
questions de changement climatique je
pense qu'elle devrait le faire avec la
chine on est un petit peu ce qui se
passe
françois hollande va se rendre en chine
juste avant la coupe 21 oui oui oui il
va le faire une fois mais ça dans on est
par ailleurs en train de négocier un
traité de libre échange avec les états
unis un homme le taffetas qui en cours
de discussion etc
donc il va allait causer hollande mais
dans les fêtes on n'est pas du tout en
train de discuter de quelque chose qui
est très fort avec avec la chine on est
en train de discuter d'un machin qui est
bon ce cause parce que quand même vous
êtes les premiers émetteurs de co2 mais
mais enfin la lacc au 21 ans occupe
beaucoup l'espace médiatique et puis le
président françois hollande en a fait un
petit peu son cheval de bataille
vous pensez que malgré tout ça dans le
fond les choses ne changent pas tant que
ça ça va pas avoir un effet discriminant
ni dans un sens ni dans l'autre de même
que copenhague dont on a dit que c'était
un échec ce qui est pas mon avis a pas
eu non plus d'effets discriminant dans
un sens ni dans l'autre
copenhague a eu un effet médiatique
majeur très positif c'est que c'est de
cette époque que date l'objectif des
deux degrés copenhague a installé
l'objectif des deux degrés ça c'est un
succès fantastique
donc j'ai pas du tout un échec à
copenhague
c'est le dernier c'est le dernier virage
un peu significatif qu'ils aient eu lieu
dans les négociations internationales et
les ong ont appelé ça un échec parce que
c'est elle qu'on tirait les premières
pour deux raisons la première c'est que
les danois avaient prévu quinze mille
personnes maximum dans le centre de
conférence et la deuxième semaine des
négociations entre les délégations
nationales et la presse y avait quinze
mille personnes donc il y avait plus de
place pour les ong qui ont été limitées
à 90 personnes elles étaient des
milliers la première semaine 90
représentants des ong la deuxième qu'il
était énervé comme pas possible accord
donc c'était assez facile pour redire
que ça allait être un échec et la
deuxième raison pour laquelle ils ont
qualifié sa d'échec c'est que le
processus qui s'est installée la
deuxième semaine a été un processus
parfaitement donne onusien en fait c'est
le g20 ou une conférence des présidents
qui s'est invité en plein milieu d'un
processus onusien qui est un processus
consensuel par acclamation un machin etc
c'est sarkozy qui a dit un certain
nombre de ses homologues etc je tiens ça
de sources très sûres
on peut pas repartir de là sans avoir
rien décidé donc on va tous se mettent
dans une salle et on en sort en s'étant
mis d'accord sur un certain nombre de
choses et c'est exactement ce qui s'est
passé dans la nuit du jeudi au vendredi
de la deuxième semaine et on est
ressorti de la salle avec une feuille de
papier sur laquelle il y avait 12 points
d'accord donc par 400 pages 12 points
d'accord dont les deux degrés dont les
100 milliards dont un certain nombre de
trucs dont on discute aujourd'hui
donc en gros on a fait une conférence
des présidents mais évidemment c'était
un procédé brutale parce que dans ce
procédé on arrête d'avoir les îles
tuvalu qui votent pour une voix comme
les états unis dans ce procédé c'est les
gros et les puissants qui disent nous on
est d'accord là dessus puis les autres
vous allez vous mettre au diapason et ça
les ong ont pas supporté
oui mais elles ont confondu la brutalité
du processus au principe de cette
conférence si l on confondre oui mais
sauf que le principe de la conférence il
produira rien justement elles ont
confondu la brutalité du processus
avec le manque d'intérêt du résultat
elles ont confondu les deux choses le
processus était un peu brutal mais le
résultat extrêmement intéressant
beaucoup plus intéressant que ce qui
avait été produit les années précédentes
et donc la conférence de paris je ne
suis pas capable de dire ce qu'elle va
produire
par contre ce que je sais c'est que le
le nombre de gens aujourd'hui qu'ils ont
envie qu'on s'avance
on avance pardon pour des raisons
parfaitement égoïste certaines
entreprises un certain nombre de
mouvements citoyens un certain nombre de
gens qui se disent dans l'arbitrage
entre ce que je mange aujourd'hui et le
monde dans lequel vont vivre mes enfants
mais je n'ai pas envie qu'on soit
submergé de réfugiés qui fuient les
guerres comme c'est déjà en train de se
passer
j'ai pas envie que les canicules fille
sur les maisons comme c'est déjà en
train de se passer
j'ai pas envie de courir le risque etc
de ceci cela donc je suis pour bouge
et bien ça c'est en train de monter
progressivement et paris ou pas paris ça
monte
le cumul de ces égoïsmes exagéré dans le
sens faut en réunir suffisamment pour
que ça aille dans le bon sens alors le
cumul des égoïsmes ne fait pas l'intérêt
collectif
mais quand il va dans le sens de
l'intérêt collectif saeed est donc alors
le processus reste troublant pas de
trucs à dire mais globalement il ya un
mouvement de fond qui est parti et pour
finir sur les états unis
à mon avis les états unis malgré le fait
qu'obama est probablement un homme
intéressant c'est le pays qui est le
plus mal armé de la terre pour s'occuper
sérieusement du problème
le président n'a pas le pouvoir
législatif et il l'a pas du tout c'est à
dire qu'à la différence de la france où
c'est le gouvernement qui est à l'ordre
du jour du parlement aux etats unis
c'est le parlement qui fait lors du jour
du parlement
aux etats unis une loi doit être voté
dans les mêmes termes dans les deux
chambres
sinon elle passe pas l'adoption de
décrets n'existe pas donc lillois doit
comprendre ces décrets d'application et
la mandature des élus à la chambre des
représentants change tous les deux ans
donc vous n'avez jamais le temps de
pondre un texte ficelé de 1000 pages
donc avec ces décrets d'application en
france c'est bien qu'en france donc un
président il fait voter une loi
emblématique aux états unis mais elle
n'en fait pas voter deux ayant fait
voter une donc ya pas et la loi macro et
la loi de transition et la loi ceux ci
et là où cela est la loi sur la sécurité
ça n'existe pas et la loi sur le mariage
pour tous je dis pas que je suis
d'accord ou pas d'accord avec ce qui est
voté jeudi juste en france le président
il fait voter plein de lois
emblématiques qui après sont impliqués
ou pas du reste aux etats unis le temps
d'une mandature quand vous
fait voter une c'est le bout du monde
donc la solution ce serait plutôt du
côté de la chine alors la chine
al'avantage de ses inconvénients
elle a toujours un pouvoir central qui
est fort elle a toujours un pouvoir
central autocratique donc haletant
devant lui ou car en tout cas qu'il ya
plus de temps devant lui et c'est un
pays qui à la différence des états unis
à une communauté d'histoire avec
l'europe qui est très forte
les etats unis ces domaines of plenty
donc les gens sont arrivés il y avait
quelques indiens à zigouiller et après à
- l'embellie
j'ai autant de mines que je veux autant
de pétrole que je veux autant de forêt
que je veux autant de ressources que je
veux autant d' espaces que je veux
autant de riz tous d'accord autant de
chutes d'eau que je veux autant de désir
que je veux pas juste il ya tout quoi
donc c'est un pays c'est bien pour ça
que le slogan c'est no limit
c'est un pays qui s'est fondé sur l'idée
qu'il n'y avait pas de limites c'est le
sait le pays de l'absence de limites
la chine c'est comme l'europe elle a
connu la peste elle a connu la famine
elle a connu le confinement de l'espace
elle a connu la guerre civile enfin les
états unis aussi elle a connu
l'oppression elle a connu tous là même
la même histoire qu'en europe
donc c'est une civilisation
multimillénaire qui sait ce que la
contrainte veut dire parce qu'elle l'a
vécu dans sa chair comme l'europe c'est
bon et cette similarité d'histoire en
fait ce qu'un bon connaisseur du climat
rappelle un pays plein tiers un endroit
où on sent les limites physiques
on les sent tous les jours aujourd'hui
on en soit une de plus que la pollution
urbaine et donc ça donne un fond
culturel sur lequel agir qui est
beaucoup plus puissant que celui qu'on
va trouver aux états unis je pense que
les états unis malgré les discours
sympathique d'obama sera le dernier pays
à accepter une législation très
contraignante sur le changement
climatique
là aujourd'hui leurs émissions sont en
train de baisser on le doit à deux
processus qui sont un intrus qui n'a
rien demandé à personne et l'autre une
bénédiction de la nature la premier
premier processus et la crise financière
qui a été bien plus efficaces que kyoto
puisqu'en deux ans les émissions de co2
des états unis ont baissé de 10%
donc pas de problème avec les états unis
il faut pas qu'ils signent kyoto faut
juste laisser faire les traders
ça marchera beaucoup plus vite et
beaucoup mieux et le deuxième c'est le
gaz de schiste qui a permis aux états
unis de supprimer un quart du charbon
qui consomment dans la production
électrique pour le remplacer par du gaz
qui émet moins de co2
mais ils ont rien demandé à personne ils
ont plein de roche-mère plein de gaz
tant mieux pour eux mais ils n'ont pas
fait ça pour une raison environnementale
ils ont commencé par déplacer le charbon
par du gaz parce que ça coûtait moins
cher et maintenant ils disent ex post
ah bah du coup c'est vachement bien pour
le climat a regardé comme on dit oui
mais c'est la nécessité si les affaires
mais c'était pas du tout c'était pas du
tout une raisons climatiques qui les a
conduits à faire ça alors obama en a
profité pour demander à l'agencé
environnementale américaine de mettre en
place une réglementation sur les
émissions des centrales électriques mais
en gros c'est une non contrainte
puisqu'il ne fait qu'entériner ce que
les gens sont en train de faire tout
seul pour des raisons économiques que le
gascon peu moins cher au charbon lcf la
chine en français
elle c'est fff
la chine qu'en français
alors on peut reparler un petit peu de
la chine et plus généralement des ce
qu'on appelle les pays émergents
justement on parlait précédemment de
copenhague il ya une idée très forte qui
a surgi ou qui existe est peut-être déjà
mais dont on a beaucoup parlé au moment
de cette coop
c'était celle du droit à polluer des
pays émergents donc voilà le principe
est simple ce sont les pays
industrialisés qui ont connu la
révolution industrielle
à la fin du 19e siècle qui ont qui sont
les plus responsables de ce
réchauffement climatique donc c'est à
eux de payer et les pays émergents
auraient le droit de polluer jusqu'à
atteindre le même seuil de pollution et
à ce moment là simplement se
préoccuperait de diminuer leurs
émissions
aujourd'hui les choses ont un peu changé
notamment du côté de la chine
on en est où exactement dans ce discours
il moi je le compare souvent à un
discours qu'on peut tenir sur le tabac
si vous fumez 20 cigarettes par jour et
que cette tabagie quand vous étiez
adolescent vous a permis d'avoir l'air
d'un cowboy et d'emballer toutes les
filles mais que quinze ans plus tard
vous vous rendez compte que finalement
ça valait peut-être pas le coup tu
voyais plus attendre un non plus pour
emballer les filles et pas être
dépendant de la cigarette avec par
ailleurs les veines qui commence avec la
télé etc
et puis vous êtes en face de l'ado qui
dit ben moi j'aimerais bien fumer aussi
c'est à peu près ça la situation est à
ce moment vous avez deux options
policière brutale droit et à ce moment
on va tous est malade super ou bien on
peut lui dire moi je pense que j'ai fait
une bêtise c'est pas la peine de refaire
la même et donc on va regarder ensemble
comment tu peux éviter de faire la même
pour moi je suis plutôt partisan de la
deuxième option et je pense que ça
reflète mieux le
le contexte dans lequel on est enfin on
peut les comprendre aussi
alors on peut les comprendre s'ils sont
intimement persuadés que le fait de
continuer d'essayer de se hisser à notre
niveau de consommation de combustibles
fossiles est un truc sans contrepartie
mais c'est pas un truc sans contrepartie
sarah croit le la perturbation
climatique global dont ils prendront
leur part et même plus que leur part
bon donc l'idée que c'est un mouvement
d'ensemble dans lequel ils n'ont que des
aspects gagnant c'est un truc qu'il faut
qu'on se sorte de la tête
d'accord c'est juste il participe un
tout petit peu au banquet tout de suite
pour une participation certaine à la
gueule de bois demain donc le donc il
vaut peut-être mieux raisonner de
manière un peu différente
alors le raisonnement un peu différent
par contre et on va retomber sur un
problème de qui paye une passe il passe
par le fait que les produits les
produits par d'autres
les formations professionnelles il passe
par le fait que les pays dits développés
ne peuvent pas tenir un double discours
qui est à la fois fait des efforts et
cet effort que je vous demande alors que
c'est aussi mon intérêt à moi puisque
vous allez préserver un bien commun dans
je profite et je refuse de partager
l'effort avec vous ah oui évidemment les
pays développés doivent faire des
efforts et l'emporté alors ils doivent à
la fois faire des efforts en propre et
partager l'effort avec les autres parce
que c'est leur intérêt égoïste
j'ai donné deux exemples aujourd'hui il
ya des procédés émergents qui permettent
en ce qui concerne les émissions de co2
des centrales à charbon de les attraper
dans les fumées on va dire capture du
co2 et la séquestration c'est à dire que
ge après je mets le co2 dans un accueil
faire profond où il je vais l'injecter
et il va plus bouger pendant longtemps
ce procédé la six mois je suis citoyen
du monde jeudi avec l'argent de mes
impôts je suis prêt à ce que on le donne
gratuitement aux gens qui est des
centrales à charbon parce que ça va me
coûter un peu d'argent mais ça participe
de la prime d'assurance
j'ai déjà évoqué sur cette antenne
et ça va aider à préserver qui va et je
sais très bien que si on n'aide pas les
gens qui ont des centrales à charbon à
faire ça en leur donnant la techno alors
pendant plus exactement la techno mais
avec l'argent du contribuable
donc je suis l'industriel qui a ce truc
là j'ai pas de raison de la donner parce
que sinon je fais faillite
par contre que l'argent public serve à
payer l'industriel pour qu'ils aillent
faire ce genre de truc là où c'est utile
moi ça me va très bien
ça me paraît plus pertinent que de payer
des panneaux photovoltaïques en france
donc il ya un certain nombre de choses
qu'on pourrait faire et ça me semblerait
légitime qu'on fasse ça avec mon argent
des contribuables parce que ça
correspond à mon intérêt égoïste de
vivre mois plus tard et mes enfants
après mois dans un monde qui va pas être
mis à feu et à sang
j'ai tout à fait prêts à payer pour ça
simplement à ce moment ça revient à ce
que les pays dits développés acceptent
un certain nombre de choses
qu'aujourd'hui ils n'acceptent pas par
exemple que le contribuable prenne à sa
charge des transferts de technologies
par exemple que le contribuable prenne à
sa charge un certain nombre
d'équipements qui vont éviter aux pays
dits en voie de développement de se
mettre un peu plus près de là où on est
parce que je pense qu'ils y arriveront
j'avais la montagne un peu plus preneur
matière de ressources accessibles ça
passera pas quoi donc mais un peu plus
près de la monnaie ça ok juste pour
donner un exemple aujourd'hui il ya un
milliard de voitures en circulation dans
le monde
le taux d'équipement en france et dans
une voiture pour deux habitants
si j'applique ça à la population
planétaire de 7 ou 8 milliards de bons
hommes ça revient à multiplier le nombre
de voitures en circulation par 3,4
c'est totalement incompatible avec
l'offre mondiale de pétrole
l'offre mondiale de pétrole plus le
carburant c'est incompatible avec fin
juste ça passe par quoi
donc c'est enfin voilà donc un exemple
il y en a plein d'autres
donc le lemay mais pour en revenir à la
question de ckoi le deal à passer entre
les pays développés et les pays dits en
développement il ya un moment il faut
qu'on considère que l'on est dans le
même vaisseau spatial qui s'appelle la
planète terre qu'on ne va pas de
rechange et donc on sert un peu les
coudes et ça ça passe par des mécanismes
d'entr'aide qui sont des mécanismes
légitime alors la raison pour laquelle
ça ne se fait pas aujourd'hui on en
revient après un premier point qu'on a
souvent évoqué le défaut de connaissance
c'est à dire que le défaut de
compréhension du fait qu'on est face à
un problème qui est vraiment
susceptibles de nous pourrir grandement
la vie fait qu' il ya un défaut de
motivation et d'acceptation de l'effort
si vous pensez vraiment j'ai donné un
exemple idiot vous êtes devant quelqu'un
qui ne sait pas nager et qui vient de
tomber dans la seine l'effort de vous y
jetez vous même alors que l'eau est à 10
degrés que etc
vous vous dites c'est pas le sujet je
partage les forts je plonge je fais ce
que je peux parce que vous avez une
compréhension claire du risque vous
savez là le risque en ce qui concerne le
changement climatique la compréhension
du risque
elle n'est pas suffisamment diffusé donc
là on retombe sur un problème partagé de
qui a voix au chapitre dans les micros
et enfin
et comment est ce que les rédactions
pour leur tri on partage delà du
problème qui n'est pas suffisant et
derrière il ya donc une motivation à
agir qui n'est pas suffisante mais si la
motivation à agir et là on a plein de
moyens de se serrer un peu les coudes et
de dire on va faire un peu plus est chez
nous aussi on va commencer à faire un
peu plus pour se protéger contre un
avenir qui échapperaient totalement à
notre emprise alors justement cette
prise de conscience aujourd'hui quand
même elle est à son maximum on on peut
dire que c'est notamment en chine
justement puisque c'est c'était un petit
peu ce dont on parlait à l'instant où
les effets de cette pollution sont
particulièrement visibles les scandales
se succèdent en matière sanitaire
alimentaire le fog qui qui a recouvert
une grande partie de la chine
on sait que les cours d'eau sont pollués
que les sols sont pollués etc
les gens sont inquiets réellement à
titre personnel pour leur santé pour
leurs enfants
c'est probablement la santé est
indéterminée temps est une invitation à
l'action puissante en général y compris
de choses qui conduisent à des
restrictions
quelque chose qu'on sait et le jeu
connaît pas exactement quel est le degré
d'information de la population en chine
sur le changement climatique et ses
risques
je sais qu'il ya une partie des gens qui
commencent à se soucier du problème
puisque si je suis bien informé et la
chine a par exemple entrepris des
travaux à ses pharaoniques pour être
capable d'acheminer de l'eau d'un bout à
l'autre du pays
donc c'est de la zone de mousson vers le
nord si j'ai bien compris
donc c'est quand même la traduction du
fait qu'il ya des gens quelque part qui
doivent se dire oh c'est peut-être
susceptible de changer faux concernant
occupe et il se passe en chine un autre
déterminant puissant à l'action qui est
que il ya un autre effet que le co2 dans
une partie de ce qui se passe en chine
et notamment la pollution urbaine du aux
centrales à charbon
qui engendre une envie que ça change qui
est à plus court terme la pollution est
un poil de courtes et on pense pas
forcément 2005 ces chiens là c'est
plutôt la semaine prochaine et ça c'est
quelque chose qui évidemment va dans le
bon sens c'est à dire que l'est encore
une fois l'intérêt individuel absolument
va dans le sens de l'intérêt collectif
et comme dans tout pays normalement
constitué il ya un élément de pression
qui est en général assez fort c'est le
sentiment d'inconfort des élites
urbaines quand les élites urbaines sont
incommodés par quelque chose
en général on finit par s'en occuper
donc à part ici les crottes de chiens et
en chine c'est la pollution aux
centrales à charbon et à ce moment on
fait vraiment quelque chose pour ça lcf
ici la chine en français
où